i just want to wish my friends and
family
happy thanksgiving wish i could be there
love you guys and i hope to see you soon
happy thanksgiving happy holidays to my
wife naomi
my son my man 50 grand and my daughter
my girl cinnamon swirl
daddy loves you and i hope to see you
soon later i'd like to send a message to
covid19
i better not screw up my travel plan so
if you could just leave by the time i
get back
that'd be great god bless america and
the raiders
so nice cinnamon swirl gotta love that
well those are some of our service men
and women overseas giving a holiday
shout out to folks back home
welcome back to cbs this morning last
week the pentagon announced plans to
bring back
thousands of u.s troops from iraq and
afghanistan
the u.s is expected to withdraw about
500 of the 3
000 troops currently based in iraq about
a thousand are still serving in syria
holly williams is traveling with the
service members stationed in both
countries to see how they are spending
this thanksgiving
amid the pandemic for many serving in
the middle east there'll be no
festive thanksgiving lunch today instead
they're practicing strict social
distancing
with take out meals on this base in
northern iraq
over a hundred service members have been
infected with covert
but specialist sharif tajania bimbola a
mechanic who services apache attack
helicopters
told us there's still plenty to feel
thankful for
i just love the uniform i love the
respect
i love when they call you yes sir yes
sir yes sir i love when people just
respect you
tj as he's known here came to the us
from nigeria
four years ago then enlisted and said he
plans to become a u.s citizen when this
tour of duty is over
i'm feeling grateful that i'm uh i'm on
the path
to make a better life for my family
to make a better future for my child the
base's chief medical officer is
commander chris call
an anesthetist from walter reed medical
center who
thought he was coming here to treat
combat injuries it's exactly like our
icu we have the same equipment
instead he's been setting up quarantine
wards covett has really united us as a
humanity on this base as opposed to all
of our individual units it's really in a
lot of ways brought us together
in a way that i never could have
imagined across the border in syria
at this small camp in the desert
specialist jessie shatilov from tulsa
oklahoma
is in charge of making sure there's
running water for the troops here
she was inspired to join up by her
grandfather who served in vietnam
and sent this message to her
four-year-old son victor
who she hasn't seen in five months i
love you
i miss you mom will be home soon
it and out on patrol in syrian towns and
villages
sergeant william mills a paratrooper
with the 82nd airborne division
who hails from maryland told us that at
a time when he's missing his family
he's grateful for moments like these
with local children
it kind of takes your mind elsewhere you
know you kind of forget like the
situation you're in
it's nice to kind of you know just relax
and hang out
being thousands of miles from home in
the midst of a pandemic
has given some here a new perspective on
what it means to be thankful
for cbs this morning holly williams in
syria
and we salute our fighting men and women
in uniform all over the world
serving to keep us safe yes we do
thanksgiving happy thanksgiving to them